i'm really excited about this paper i'm
talking about today it's actually uh a
paper that started out as as sort of a
labor of love and a side project so i
was actually working on it off and on
for about three years um
and in the end it ended up tying
together a lot of ideas
um it is going to be presented at csew
in
vancouver uh next year so you're getting
a little bit of a preview and this is
actually going to be longer than the
actual talk
so i'm going to be talking about
a model that i developed with my
co-author and student drew payne called
a model of coordinated action
so
first
i wanted to talk a little bit about i'm
going to share about my research program
so i just have two slides on that
and then i'm going to launch into the
discussion of the model at hand all
right
so my research program is looking at how
information systems
can be stable for current needs and
flexible to accommodate change and
innovation all right so i'm looking
often at anything from the group level
to the organization level i'm looking at
change in innovation
and i'm really concerned and interested
in designing sustainable organizations
designing sustainable practices and
designing sustainable systems all right
and these are some threads that tie
together a lot of the different research
projects i've been working on mainly in
the realm of scientific cyber
infrastructures or large scale
information systems that support
scientific collaboration
so i have a few projects going on there
my research is almost entirely
qualitative research looking at how
groups create and use systems
the fields of computer supported
cooperative work is my sort of bread and
butter as my intellectual home
i've spent a lot of time there and
there's many ways to draw this venn
diagram but this is one of the ways that
i scope it out
looking at computer-supported
cooperative work is happening in this
overlap between
organizational studies uh human computer
interaction and science and technology
studies
so that can help you situate some of my
work
all right and my work on scientific
cyber infrastructures is definitely fed
into the development of of this model
all right so back to the to the work at
hand
so in order to understand the relevance
and the import of this model it's
important to go back in time a little
bit
looking at computer-supported
cooperative work
and some of the origins of
computer-supported cooperative work
so what is computer-supported
cooperative work so the term was coined
in 1984
by grief and cashman and so csew as a
term has not been around very long
and it's looking at how collaborations
and activities can be supported
by computer systems
now historically groupware
which is software for to support small
groups has been the focus of csew
textbooks in the mid-90s would say uh
that groupware was the practice of the
research of cscw
but csew like any technologically
oriented field has been going through a
great deal of change
so computerized technologies and the
practices they support continue to grow
in diversity ubiquity complexity and
scale we all know that many of us in the
room are working on that today
and the number of type of research
topics similarly have also continued to
proliferate
so because of this proliferation and and
the constant change in flux and
technology and the scope of what we're
studying it's becoming increasingly
urgent to find ways to describe the
problem space
in which cscw
workers
researchers are working
all right
so even early on in csew i mentioned the
term was coined in 1984 as early as 1992
schmidt and bannon
who are
you know recently received a lifetime
achievement award for uh
establishing
uh csew and europe
pointed to the need to expand the scope
of cscw so this actually started
happening pretty early in the csew
ancient bin had said we need to push for
uh looking at research in settings that
are unstable large open and diverse
all right so already there was was this
sort of uh conceptual frame about what
was the scope of csew was happening as
early as 92.
in csew and again these are gross
generalizations
but european csew had historical focus
that included studies of organizations
and looking at more heterogeneous
organizations
on the other hand again a generalization
the usc csew has this historical focus
on smaller groups groupware and more
homogeneous groups
and so the
because of the size of the cscw
community versus the european community
uh some of the gravitas towards the
theoretical development also tended
towards these smaller groups
so you may ask what is a model of csew
so models of csew in the context of this
talk and the paper forthcoming paper
refer to conceptual models that posit
the elements that compose
computer support and cooperative
work so the elements that compose the
scw
the models thus far of csew and i'm
going to talk about some in a minute
have largely been descriptive
and today our model is also descriptive
but hopefully we'll push it beyond that
a little bit
and so for this talk when i talk about
models of cscw i'm talking about models
that are posited as being comprehensive
of cscw
because there are actually a lot of
models that take parts of cscw and some
of them are mentioned in the paper but
this one's comprehensive
all right so how many of you are
familiar with johansen's matrix
yeah all right so a number of people and
it it's manifested a little bit
differently than sometimes but this is
actually the actual terminology that was
used in the original 1998 text of
johansen's matrix where he talks about
the um the two dimensions of
asynchronous city and and location so
are people co-located are they
distributed are they synchronous or
asynchronous
so you don't need to focus too much on
the details there but i wanted to put
that up um
because historically this is a very
important table
all right so for those of you who raised
your hands about knowing the matrix how
many of you are familiar with this table
all right that's the usual response
so if you go back and look at the
original text
this matrix and this table are posited
as equally important
but if you look at the hci textbooks
today they only mention
this matrix
so what's interesting about that
is that and again you don't have to get
too much into the details i just wanted
to show you some primary material
um
is that johansson recognizes the need to
also study large groups
the original matrix you'll notice it's
actually specifically calls out meetings
all right that meetings are very
important to csew very important to
groupware but johansen actually in his
original work said we need to talk about
large groups as well
but this there's no mention of this in
our hci textbooks
only of the matrix
all right
so here's another model from 1994 by
jonathan gruden
where if you look at it you'll see
organizations projects small groups and
individuals now in the actual text he
says csew
draws upon adventures into these other
circles but he says csew research its
home is in small groups
all right
so i'll come back to that in a second so
johansen's taxonomy is considered a
taxonomy of tools but if you think about
it it's also
implicitly a framework describing work
itself and what are the salient
most important aspects of collaborative
work
now it's specious to suggest that many
cscw researchers still consider the
matrix to be representative of cscw
research today
but it's also true that it's still
considered to be
the traditional way
to decompose the scw and so the
textbooks actually use those words
so this model is sort of stepping into
this this moment of time where csrv is
facing this existential crisis
you know
i'm cscw why am i csew you know
and
and so a new conceptual model is needed
that can help us to understand cscw as a
comprehensive and coherent design field
and you know i talk about this in the
paper that a lot of the pressures in
american csew today
is because of some of the research that
we're already doing looking at uh
large-scale information infrastructures
and the development of them these are
very complex organizational systems with
a lot of different stakeholders
but also and i know a lot of you in this
room are studying crowdsourcing mass
participation but that's also putting a
lot of pressure in csuw to look at
larger scale collaborations
why because a lot of the things that
people are doing for example through
twitter are essentially organizational
formation
you know so we start looking at twitter
which is a very simple
uh
uh you know technology but then we find
that these very complex organizational
forms are being created partly
leveraging that
so this question is arisen what is the
phenomenon of study in computer
supported cooperative work
if johansen's matrix is outdated if
groupware is not comprehensive anymore
what is it that we're studying
so i'm going to go into you know a sort
of little theoretical background here
but that ties into the everyday practice
of csuw
that the work that's happening today
especially about that pressure and
crowdsourcing and information
infrastructures is pushing the borders
of csew
so let's talk a little bit about the
theoretical concept of articulation work
so articulation work is making sure
the various resources needed to
accomplish something are in place and
functioning when needed in a local
situation
the resources are in place and
functioning when needed in a local
situation
and this work was uh was uh this concept
was posited by anselm strauss
sociologist and he talks about the
spectra
of collaborative work projects falling
on a continuum from simple to complex
and you can think of some of your own
collaborations that you're involved in
or that you're studying think about are
they simple or are they complex
so articulation work is implicitly
reliant upon this notion of the common
field of work
all right so what is the common field of
work so the common field of work is the
site of action for coordinative work
it's constituted by the interdependents
and multiple actors who in their
individual activities in changing the
state of their individual field of work
also change the state of the field of
work of others and who thus interact
through changing the state of a common
field of work
all right so this seems pretty
complicated and pretty pretty hard to
understand but
i have an example that i'm going to talk
about in a minute but interaction
through a common field of work is
considered a fundamental distinction of
cooperative work all right
so the example i give in the paper is
this notion of a food bank right
the common field of work is that they're
somebody who's hungry
who needs food and we want to give them
food
so a person gets into their car
they load up some canned goods in their
car and they drive it to a food drive at
a shopping mall and they leave it
in the shopping mall
the interesting thing is that even
though they've undertaken this work they
haven't actually changed the common
field of work which is the person who
needs canned goods in their cupboard to
cook that night
all right so is the common field of work
actually at the food bank that's going
to receive the shopping mall or is it
something else some people would argue
well actually in this case then the
common field of work is the shopping
mall where they're collecting the food
but they haven't actually changed the
status
of
the hungry person all right so there's a
degree of separation
and not too many people in the field of
csew have really you know
focused on these theoretical
perspectives uh there are some arguments
that you know okay csew doesn't create
its own theory i'm trying to help change
that
uh there have been some folks fluttering
around the the edges of cscw have been
working on this dr ellahu gerson right
there is one of them
and um
we're very lucky to have someone who's a
product of the chicago school of
sociology in our community
um
but so i'm taking a slightly different
spin on things that there may be
multiple overlapping common fields of
work
that people may be working in a
concerted and coordinated fashion and
have compatible but slightly different
goals and you can imagine this in any
large system development you know
situation people are belong to different
departments people who are different
stages of their careers may have
slightly different goals yet they all
manage to work together in an
organization
so the spectra of strauss's where he
talks about routine to non-routine and
simple to complex is helpful
but it doesn't quite go far enough
because there are many ways in which a
collaboration can be routine or
non-routine or simple to complex and
there's many aspects to many different
kinds of collaborative work
all right so
this model is an attempt to to kind of
push some of these ideas a little
further
so why why do we call it a model of
coordinated action rather than of
cooperative work
because the field is computer support
well it has to do with that notion of
the common field of work and
articulation where coordinated action
frees us from having to decide on only
one common field of work and only one
clear-cut goal
okay it's actually holding us back from
the phenomena that researchers are
already studying
and it's removing this bias towards
smaller tightly knit cooperative
configurations and allows rooms to study
large more loosely knit coordinated
actions
this doesn't mean we stop studying small
groups because small groups are still
important but that we make room to study
these larger collaborations and also the
interaction very importantly between the
small groups and the larger groups
so we turn choose the word action to
emphasize the importance of goal
directedness
implied by the word
work while also opening up space to talk
about things that we might not typically
think of as work like serious leisure or
relationship work
so in this model of
coordinated action
we pause at seven dimensions the first
dimension should be quite familiar to
you by now because they're the same
dimensions that we had in johannes
matrix
you're referred to as synchronicity and
physical distribution and those terms
are used by some other
takes on johansen's matrix as well
um so i'm going to talk about each of
these dimensions one at a time but i
wanted to show you that these are
continuums it's not either or one or the
other but there's a continuum of being
more or less any of these seven
dimensions so i'm going to take them one
at a time
so the first dimension is synchronicity
which we discussed a little bit this
continuum of coordinated action ranging
from being conducted synchronously or at
the same time to asynchronously or
different times i'm not going to talk
about that much because it's been talked
about a lot
again same thing with dimension two it's
also been talked about a lot physical
distribution the continuum which covers
concerns whether coordinated actions are
taking place in the same geographic
regions or different ones
all right
so the interesting about scale is we all
think about scale and scale is referred
to in the papers but obliquely
but we know from coordination theory
that scale matters because as soon as
you go beyond a very small number of
collaborators they need to do a lot of
articulation work that is
there's a lot of activity that needs to
be done just to organize people in order
to get anything done all right so scale
does matter
dimension 4 is number of communities of
practice
so communities of practice is a
framework itself it's actually a very
developed theory
my work on by
wenger and love but we're only taking
one aspect of this we're talking about
number of communities of practice and
this is focus
specifically on the notion of different
cultural communities or a certain type
of intellectual
diversity so the simplest way to think
about that is people from different
disciplines coming together trying to
collaborate
you know if you have a designer and you
have a software engineer and you have a
educator and you have a historian
they're going to come with different
real world views different values
different ways of doing things and so
we're trying to get here at a certain
type of cultural diversity when we talk
about number of communities of practice
now in the paper we talk about
being salient whether these communities
of practice are represented
so for example you could have a design
team of seven people from several
different domains and we would consider
that to have seven communities of
practice or you could have seven teams a
team of all software engineers a team of
all designers for example a team of all
architects and maybe that would be three
so it's talking about this cultural gap
that needs to be bridged in order to
come up with common nomenclatures common
common ways of working even sometimes
articulating what the common goal is
all right so dimension five
is nascent
so this is
unestablished versus established
coordinations
and i want to really underline that it's
not merely a simple synonym for newness
rather it applies a sort of coming into
being
a special kind of
if you will instability rife with future
potentialities
it's like a little bit of poetry in
there for you
all right so we might see nascents you
know in a reformed and rebooted
coordination so it's not just a matter
of we just started working together but
it's but it's also like the ground is
shifting under us and we're not sure
what's happening so for example economic
pressures or somebody uh quitting could
cause instability causing people have to
reform
how
established and on the ground this
coordination feels
all
right another one is planned permanence
or the intended permanence of a
coordinated action
so i want to emphasize why we call it
planned permanence we can't plan because
we can't really know how permanent
something is going to be someone could
set up a collaboration saying yeah this
is designed to last for five years you
know 10 years it's going to be awesome
but we don't really know the funding
gets pulled in year three then you know
it's not going to current so we can only
can talk about planned permanent
but think about why it matters
all right
it matters because and i and the paper i
give an example is a family who's going
to the forest and they're setting up
camp they're going to stay there for you
know five days
versus family that's moving to the
forest and they're planning on
staying there for ten years
what kinds of preparations would you
take place if you're taking your family
to the woods for five days versus if
you're taking your family to the woods
for 10 years or more
we're going to put a lot of more effort
into planning all kinds of articulation
work accumulating resources it becomes a
very different type of collaboration
than it's quick and dirty let's get a
campsite let's get a tent we'll get
dirty we'll roll around in the middle be
awesome
all right
so dimension seven is turnover
and this is the stability of the
participant makeup of a given
collaboration
the rapidity with which participants
enter and leave okay so i know some of
you who are looking at crowdsourcing are
looking at collaborations where there's
very rapid turnover there's very little
stability
so some people ask me why do you have a
separate one for turnover and nascents
and i want to say that's because there
are situations where something can have
a lot of turnover but not be very
nascent uh or the other way around it's
true they often come together
and these dimensions are not meant to be
mutually exclusive right but they can
vary together uh but also differ
all right
okay so
these are the the seven dimensions of
the model of coordinated action all
right so what are some of the
implications of this that we've gone
from johansen's two dimensions into
these seven dimensions
you know why
what's the the relevance of this
entire model
well one is this notion of coordinated
action that coordinated action can still
be conceived of as people
working together towards a shared goal
you know because i know in my early work
when i was first getting started in this
study of scientific collaborations okay
these very
large gooey collaborations with
different teams and and uh
it was
very you know open-ended and some of the
reviewers would say but how is this csew
you know this is this is this is a mess
or this is more you know i don't know
what this is this isn't
collaboration
um but we're seeing a lot of that happen
in our
and our the fun on we're looking at
right
and to acknowledge that shared goals can
be only very loosely shared sometimes it
can be very diffuse and ill-defined
and also to see that working working
together
can be people working rather separately
separately on different systems that
still need to operate with a larger more
sprawling infrastructure
okay
that many organizations and computing
systems are personally but not
completely interoperable all right
we've come a long way from this sense of
people working together if it's a
functioning good collaboration should
all have a very good sense of what's
going on with whom and how
well a lot of the research we've done
and we've seen now say that people often
don't have a very good idea of who's
doing what with how with whom and how
but they still manage to get the job
done
you know so there's element of
how much
shared understanding do you need in
order for it to be good enough for the
work at hand
all right
and that often these overlapping and
non-congruent interests
and priorities are okay
so one of the other things the
implications for this model is to to
shine the light on this notion of
emergence okay and in the the paper if
you you know care to seek it out later i
have a whole section that's just a fire
hose of people in cscw talking about
emergence essentially for the last 10 or
11 years but never quite getting
traction you know so i put together the
whole fire hose for you and you can
ingest it
so that coordinated actions that exhibit
social emergence are becoming even more
ubiquitous in our research
all right
and
that it's increasingly relevant to
everyday life given the extended reach
of social media and information
technologies okay and this notion of
social emergence uh there's a
sociologist um artie sawyer who has a
whole book on it which is very dense but
fun
and he talks about how
larger systems and he's not the only one
but i liked his his take on it but he
talks about how larger systems influence
smaller systems and smaller systems
interact with larger systems now smaller
interactions impact uh smaller
collaborations and what we're doing as
people in human computer interaction is
inserting ourselves inserting our
technologies
into different parts of this whole
system of practices and understandings
trickling up and trickling down in these
collaborations okay
so if we're creating a very small
application for a small group of people
that can have ripple effects for the
larger collaboration larger organization
similarly if you're looking at people at
a large infrastructure where it's very
top-down that sometimes will be
you know
very direct impacts on the collaboration
from the top down that also influence
the type of technology that's desired
accepted etc
all right
and so that
a lot of times what we're doing
are we're not designing a solution but
we're actually designing an intervention
into a much bigger problem or a much
bigger design space
okay
so one of the things that i'm pushing
for with this model is for us to be a
little more reflective about what are we
trying to do when we're trying to insert
these technologies into these social
systems into the social media if we just
you know the butterfly flapping its
wings we put the butterfly right here
what are the ripple effects okay
so having these emergent qualities is a
fundamental reality of many of these
contemporary coordinated actions
the challenge of designing to support
emergence becomes increasingly as
important as we consider more types of
coordinated action that are complex or
more extreme on any of those seven
dimensions that we talked about
whether it's like extremely high
turnover or it's a very small scale et
cetera any of the extremes
so how can we make sense of the types of
coordinated action making a new model
uh such as smoke unnecessary and i'm not
positing this as the one model that will
roll them all but i'm rather trying to
get a conversation started saying
can't we consider some of these things
all right
what does it mean to do collaborative
work cooperative work because we're
modeling sociality whether we
acknowledge it or not every time we
design a collaborative system
so let's just put that up into the light
for inspection
so the notion of emergence is not new to
csew but it's kind of been just
flittering around on the edges and so
i'm just trying to shine a light on it
and
and to consider this notion of emergent
coordinated action as one way of
describing some of these ways of working
all right
so this
touches on many years of empirical
research you know the interesting thing
is i didn't think this paper would be
accepted because i didn't collect any
new data for this study um so i was
thrilled when when when it was accepted
this is after a couple rejections
but it did make the paper better
but it touches on many many years of
empirical research
and it's still an early step in a larger
project to contribute to theory that
originates from the cscw community that
is for the cscw community
all right
and
and we propose here a particularly
particular kind of theoretical
theoretically driven empirical program
all right
so we want to
promote this development of other
conceptual frameworks that put all
manner of research and
technologies that support coordinated
action
in conversation with each other
all right
so what if we continue to work and
develop on this and develop this model
which is our goal what are some of the
practical implications of this right in
the shorter the medium term
all right
so one of the the goals would be to be
able to have a way of systematically
studying change within one coordinated
action over time
so we can see you know okay at the
beginning of this project the
collaboration looked like this on these
seven dimensions in the middle it looked
like this on the seven dimensions at the
end it looked like this on the seven
dimensions
and then what were the implications then
for the different types of technology
that people used that they rejected that
they adopted
that there's to have a way of
systematically teasing apart these as
socio-technical
um
sociotechnical configurations
all right but also differences and
similarities within particular domains
so what kind of differences can we see
within certain health collaborations
but also difference in similarities
within particular types of activity so
we look at all the studies of mass
participation or infrastructure
development what are the what kind of
diversity do we see there
but also interesting across you know
differences across domains and spheres
of activity we've gotten to the point of
maturity in csew where it's like all
wikipedia scholars hang out with each
other and they know their research and
all the scientific infrastructure
collaborating you know folks get
together and they know each other's
research
we're getting to a point where we're
gonna we have already started missing
opportunities across these disciplinary
silos
but consider that a small nascent
collaboration
in a science lab might have more in
common with a small decent collaboration
on twitter than very established
collaborations
in similar realms
all right
so it's a way of having a dialogue
across
methodological and disciplinary divides
and so one of the the things that could
be interesting is the development of a
way to index different coordinated
actions at the time of data collection
you know for so for example we can lower
the overhead that it takes in order to
study similar types of research
that are studying similar types of
problems and similar types of
collaborations
if at the time of data collection people
go like okay you know this is the
snapshot of the seven types of
dimensions then you can search on it
later
and then we all get more traction with
the same amount of research
and then perhaps the identification of
the equivalent of personas we currently
in aci we have a lot of personas for we
develop sermons for individuals but what
if we can develop personas for different
types of collaborations based on these
seven dimensions and say okay
these types of collaborations with high
turnover high nascents large scale
they tend to need this type of
technological intervention that this
type of their development
all right
we try to find
themes
patterns
help us leverage what we're doing
okay
all right so what are some next steps
you know
and it's interesting because anytime you
start to take on theoretical work like
this it's a very very very slow moving
shift you know it takes a long time to
to develop them it takes a long time to
test them it takes a long time to
evaluate them it takes a long time to
build them
but what are some of our next steps for
this model
well one is to do a post hoc retro
retrospective content analysis of csuw
publications over time
to document changes in csew in terms of
what types of collaborations that people
when studying we expect that scale will
be something that has changed quite a
bit over time that there's more
diversity and scale now than there once
was
and also further document and describe
the seven dimensions i should mention in
the paper itself we describe the
dimensions and give examples more than i
had time to hear
but we can further articulate and
elaborate on those but also to develop
ordinal measures for the seven
dimensions because that's when we really
get some traction in the paper itself we
go through two examples one looking at
scientific cyber infrastructure
development uh they're at crowdsourcing
mass participation work uh we used some
of the work of star and palin for that
sorry starboard and palin for that
um
and in those examples we kind of just
currently measure into you know uh
low medium high for those different
dimensions to give you an example of the
kind of traction of the kind of
narratives that you can talk about there
over the longer term we want to further
develop these connection between
theories of social emergence
as they pertain to technical design
interventions so i mentioned before you
know you want to see what the ripple
effects if you insert the the technical
butterfly at you know small group level
or organizational level
what are some of the ripple effects
but maybe we can look more at that and
take more seriously csew as a
socio-technical
design field
and also conduct some large-scale meta
research
on collaborative research so if you're
familiar with the work of gary and judy
olsen's work
they attempted to do this a few years
ago on scientific collabora laboratories
of trying to get different dimensions
on to describe different types of just
scientific collaboratories but it was
difficult because that time we didn't
have some of the research that we have
now to sketch out the different
dimensions and so i think we're getting
getting closer to that
and i've been talking with judy olsen
about
expanding some of that scientific
collaboratory's work
based on
newer stuff like this model
so the smaller coordinated action is a
step into the continued exploration of
csew as a design field
and
you know one of the things i really want
to iterate is sometimes this work makes
people feel uncomfortable because people
are like this is sociology this is
social science this is not cscw
and i say to that
because i've been in this realm of cscw
since my first year as a doctoral
student you know my pg
pft advisor was a computer scientist my
postdoc advisor computer scientist
and
and there is
space in csuw for doing our own original
theoretical work that does not mean
everybody needs to be a theorist right
but there's room for this kind of work
and that we can use this kind of work to
inform our technological interventions
you know i've had numbers of points in
my career where i thought well you know
it would be really nice to be closer to
to product development but the thing is
i'm really good at this and there are a
lot of people who are really good at
product development more so than i am so
i i'm still i'm still
mining this vein all right
so
we want this better understanding of
what it means designed for
socio-technical systems that can be
socially and technically complex and
subject to frequent changes all right
so designed to support coordinated
action we need to know more about what
coordinated action is what are we
actually designing for
right
it's not a simple answer because
collaboration is not simple
the technologies we're developing are
not simple
all right
and we need to have better ways to talk
about these variations and you know
maybe with people who are doing work
like i'm doing we can get more lift
and we could get farther with the work
that we are doing
you know
technically
not just socially but both
so i like this quote from logan and
stolterman where they say design theory
is knowledge focused on creating new
conditions for design
different patterns of thinking and
acting
new design examples and a general
understanding of the conditions for
creative and innovative work
all right
so i think we definitely have room in
our field and hci
generally csew more specifically
have more design theory
so i've mentioned this before but i want
to say it again that hci researchers are
already pushing into the frontiers of
accepting and exploring
new ways of coordinated action
and our theory and conceptual frameworks
should follow suit
all right
all right thanks i'd be happy to take
any questions
or comments
oh i'm sorry
are there any existing tools or products
that you like that think that that you
think incorporate the dimensions of the
mocha framework oh
well i mean
so the mocha framework is designed to be
kind of like gps coordinates right it's
a it's a road map or a map so every
system
every collaboration and every
collaborative system should fall on the
moca somewhere
so
i guess you know i'm kind of doing an
enter run around your questions you know
any system can be me
um
yeah i guess the the short answer is no
because you know it's like
you know there are tools i like and
applications i like but you know you
know i like twitter i like facebook but
what's important about those is how they
work in context
and so it's like it's not the same as
liking the the system you know right
maybe a way of reframing that is there
is there any
that
maybe just talk about technical systems
and the right way to frame it
any socio-technical systems that you
find particularly illustrative with the
dimensions
well i mean again i can't i can't answer
the question because the dimensions are
just a map it's sort of like saying what
gps coordinate is your favorite and it's
sort of like well then this is what
place is my favorite or maybe that's
what you're asking
the utility of the dimensions or give
like that right right um well so i would
refer you to the the examples in the
paper and actually the preprint is
available online as of two days ago so
you can do that where we actually look
at for example uh humanity road which is
a collaboration uh for disaster relief
that peel and starboard write about and
they talk about these very interesting
ways that people are using twitter along
with skype and some other collaborations
to illustrate
you know how this very nascent
collaboration evolves and then we have
another example looking at scientific
cyber infrastructure so it's not even
that those are particularly good
examples but they are examples showing
how you can kick the tires and use a
model for understanding
organizational uh status as well as
change yeah oh three hands at once i'll
go from left to right uh yeah
uh so
one
nice property of the handsome framework
is that it's so far smartest and there's
two dimensions there's two values on
those two dimensions yeah it's easy to
teach
yes and
i would like to know you know what are
your thoughts and teaching people this
new framework because people have
certainly many more dimensions yes yeah
yeah i have lost sleep
over the relative inelegance of having
these seven dimensions versus the two
dimensions of johannes matrix and i
actually probably spent
10 months trying to find a way to
simplify it to make it more more
parsimonious and i just couldn't
uh i even like met with methods and i
talked with some mathematicians it's
like how would you
and they're like oh you should just have
three different tables it's like oh okay
i'm just back where i started so that's
how i ended up with a seven line so
um so yeah i i i have that same
discomfort that you do and wishing that
it was simpler but uh
and maybe you know as we develop the
framework we'll find a
you know a cleaner way to describe it
but as of now it's
this is collaboration it's messy it's
complex and i
couldn't distill it any further than
this yeah
okay yeah
um
so my question is mostly about um what
what kind of systems that we've been
studying in cscw i know these might take
there's mostly any system that has
multiple users so um i was wondering how
you feel about systems like facebook and
setting how people use them and how that
falls into your description of
coordinated work
yeah right
so
i'm sorry what's sorry is coordinated
action oh yeah that's okay
yeah actually the paper at the end i say
well i don't actually object you know i
don't i'm not upset if people use the
words cooperation or collaboration it
was just for
for
technical and precise terminology i
wanted to use coordinated action that i
don't you know object because it's a
historical term but your your question
was uh sorry your question was again
could you repeat it um i was wondering
how you feel about
people studying systems like facebook
that really falls right
yeah so this is interesting so you know
as computer scientists you're all asking
questions about specific technologies
and and to take a step back it's like i
look at i really truly see the world in
terms of socio technical
collaborations
so i look at the social part and the
technical part and i see the world as
that as that very interwoven like you
can't extricate it so facebook is just
one part of
one part of a larger set of practices
and concerns right
so it's a matter of are you using
facebook to organize parties or are you
using uh facebook to do the relationship
work of keeping up with your high school
friends
are you using uh facebook to uh to
create documents i've seen people do
that as well
so what
we're studying when we're studying the
collaborations is you know again i
mentioned that there's enough goal
directing this
so what is the goal
that some group of people are using that
technology for
okay
so then you can't take facebook out of
the collaboration of the goal or the
group of people you know
so that is that is the phenomenon of
study is this close intertwining of
particular purpose the group and then
the technology
so then you know facebook for
10 people to
create a party is very different from
the collaboration which is facebook for
a thousand people to uh
you know
uh
create an open source
you know tool or something like that
yeah all right yes in the back like
it reminds me of like personality tests
right so it's like there's a bunch of
dimensions and then and then puts you at
some point like yeah you're an entj but
i think the actual value of personality
tests are like like what you actually
get for from that right so it's like x
percentage of the population our entjs
they work well with this kind of uh
other types of of
people and
um
like
that these types of tasks i'm
i'm not sure if you thought of like
something anonymous
for your model
um yeah i mean it was hard not to in a
way you know because it's like uh you
know i've taken the myers-briggs
multiple times and
you know mapped the changes over time
then you know it was and you know
there's a lot of research sort of
debunking myers-briggs as well as there
would be for any kind of model like that
uh but it is very useful for having
those conversations about you know what
does it mean to be this on the spectrum
right and so you can imagine having
those similar types of conversations
that you know oh i might have with my
friends because you know i used to be
intp and now i'm intj isn't that cool or
isn't that weird you know um
but but yeah the expectation is that
you know it suffers from both the pros
and minuses of trying to ma dimensions
of anything you know you have that
question of how valid is it anyway
right and
you know if you're doing your
work right that's probably going to be
changing over time because you're
discovering new things over time but it
is it is a way to get some kind of
traction
uh oh wait let's take a personal comment
yeah i was gonna say that it seems like
the uh the dimensions are more useful to
be aware of what it means to be on
either side of it as opposed to you know
where you fall into it and especially if
you were to like have some sort of
employee or some sort of projects
i guess position on each of those
coordinates and if you had to pick one
side over the other you've got
two to the seven possibilities
but
i don't know in my experience as being
an intern at you know places that are
really heavily corporate
i feel like my best managers and best
mentors were aware of
you know a few of those different
dimensions and i could actually see how
they actually planned for me to do a
certain amount of work
and were very aware that you know i
would be there only for three months
this is why i'd have to hand off my work
to and
you know how much of this stuff is going
to be repetitive work and who you need
to talk to to be able to you know take
on new tasks i feel like the dimensions
are
really useful to be aware of and i could
totally see managers taking a course on
this right right right yeah and i mean
that's that's really the immediate hope
is that we put some of these ideas on
you know into people's heads so that
people actually
it's actually in the short term just a
tool for people have these kinds of
conversations you know because one of
the reasons is you know everybody knows
that collaboration is hard you know
everyone who's tried to collaborate
knows it hard and everyone who's who has
studied it knows that it's hard but the
thing is we don't know why it's hard we
don't know how to break it down it's
into its constituent parts you know some
of the research i've done recently is
looking at epidemiology research as the
fred hutchinson cancer research center
you know some of the brightest minds in
cancer research
and we're interviewing them and we tell
them about our work looking at
collaboration
and these folks who are you know working
on cancer say oh we didn't think that
was a problem that you could you could
study and and solve or you know even a
study you could tackle
you know that people think that
collaboration is just some sort of magic
untractable thing and so what we're
trying to do is break it down into
constituent parts you know maybe these
aren't the right constituent parts but
it's a start right
so that we go ahead and have these
dialogues my hope is that we actually do
get some ordinal values on that so we
get more subtlety
and we can have more nuance in those
discussions like yeah it is helpful to
know you know one extreme versus the
other extreme that's already a great
starting point for a discussion
but if we can get you know even a low
medium high or maybe even get five
values my goodness you know what could
we possibly you know end up seeing then
you know
right yeah chennai
so uh i think this relates to the
last few questions as well
you have a space but in addition to a
space there's an implicit goodness
function in some sense right so the
other space is not all that space is
equally good
so i i wonder what it would take to move
from this descriptive order to a certain
predictive model where you can say
look if you want to have a system with
high knees and see and i turn over yeah
you just can't support
interactions with 10 people at a time
you have to go to m
so what what what would get us from the
scripture
yeah yeah yeah so the first step is
getting some ordinal values of some kind
even as low medium high or whatever but
that's only the starting point right
so it's like okay
once we have low medium high we don't
only have dimensions but we actually
have coordinates you know i'm going to
use a metaphor again of gps coordinates
but that's only the beginning of the
work right the interesting thing is what
happens when you say let's go and study
everybody who's at this coordinate you
know who's like at these you know where
all the seven things they are all at you
know point three on this on seven
dimensions let's study everybody who's
doing that
and let's look at
you know how happy are they with their
collaborations or how many you know
patents or products or do they put out
how much turnover you know where you can
actually start to look at best practices
for those specific types
you know and that's one of the reasons
we have to have so many dimensions is
that there are so many different types
of collaborative ways of working that
that's the only way to capture the the
diversity but
once we can say like okay you know we
have you know i was talking about the
idea of personas before it's like we can
even go farther than personas and do
empirical research for particular types
of collaborations and say for that type
of collaboration is falling at these
places on the seven dimensions what are
they doing that's working
you know what are they doing that
they're happy about there may not even
be one right answer but we can only
start having that dialogue of figuring
out what is the goodness and then maybe
even getting into some predictive uh
modeling yeah
and again this is like a very long-term
project not a short-term project yes
yeah absolutely
is the life cycle of a collaboration
and there are basic phases that are that
are
well known
do you feel that your dimensions take
that into account that there's there's
some have a pattern of certain life
cycle phases um but others may be
different even though they i think these
attributes might be the same right if
the life cycle is a little different
yeah yeah yeah so we're talking about
the the entire span of the overall life
cycle or are you talking about something
different there might be collaborations
that are more
pulsing and consistent there's a
commonality but it's just consistent
but new new people come in and usually
come in periodically right well there
might be some
characteristic uh
phasing which is just random or it might
be the classic uh kind of
a certain set of types of taxonomy
somewhere absolutely absolutely do you
feel that that takes into account or do
you do
that
both of neither so
so
the life cycle question the temporal
aspect is very important
uh but i didn't feel prepared to put
that in the model because i didn't have
enough
data my data i mean existing cscw
research that looks at those
temporalities but i do think they're
very important so so
what's that yeah yeah uh but i think we
get at it obliquely already by the
notions of turnover nascents you know
and so one of the opportunities here is
once we have these is that we can
actually try to look at maybe some of
those temporal aspects because some of
the collaborations may evolve much more
quickly than others we would expect in a
startup
that
those ticks over would happen much
faster than in a you know a larger
organization
yeah
other questions comments on gilbert
so i'm
a little bit curious
this may be pushing a little bit back
towards you know the the computer
science and sure well we're building the
system right and
it strikes me that uh
the model that you have here is talking
about actions
or events or collaborations right
and often when we're building if we're
building a system like say
facebook or another sort of uh
social platform yeah they would call
them platforms and we think of them in
terms of perhaps architecture
or spaces or
um
you know city planning or like planning
a park
it's hard to anticipate what it's going
to be used for and it's going to be used
for a lot of different
collaborations a lot of different
actions
so i'm wondering if you thought much
about how that
slightly different uh
category of
a thing right right these platforms
which are different than the actions
yeah which yeah involves them right
right right well i mean i think it's a
question so even if you're designing a
platform it's sort of a platform for
what right and then
if you're going to design a platform you
you usually still want to think about
specific instances i think it's just
natural as a software developer that you
know you're going to think about oh but
what if people want to do this right or
what people want to do that or
you know
and
and so
you can have that discussion you know
and i i guess probably the most
cognizant or
similar thing in my own work is people
designing these scientific cyber
infrastructures they're supposed to be
infrastructures you know it's supposed
to be plug and play
but inevitably they have alpha users you
know who are just sort of like okay you
know this is supposed to be an
infrastructure for all uh people who
study environmental genomics but in
actuality we still have to design it
with somebody in mind and we can't
design it for everybody because we don't
have time money budget to do this
extensive uh study of everyone's
studying genomics so they usually start
out with some alpha testers right domain
scientists are going to go like well
this is what i do this is what i need
and they have a few of those and they
design it in i can see that being
similar in the platform development
right where you think like okay we want
everyone to use it for all kinds of
things including things we haven't
thought about but we still need a
starting point to think about so
you know maybe in terms of using this
model we can think about you know some
help us to pick who those alpha users
are going to be
right
yeah maybe
there's also some benefit of knowing
which things transfer or where
movement can happen in these dimensions
right so something developed for this
coordinate
to to what are the coordinates does that
tend to generalize effectively or not
right right right so
it's well for it works well for these
levels of you know nascents maybe it's
okay for that level of turnover or
something like that yeah i don't know
it's hard it's at this point it's
impossible to
speculate or maybe probably not even
useful but it's something fun to thought
exercise yeah right uh david
is there i think there's room in your
model
technology itself so
i was thinking about building this
question about yeah the platform but
what about things like
are you using mobile technology versus
nonverbal technology or if you're a
high-tech super rich collaborator
not so rich you know
like something so the actual technology
to themselves yeah do you think that
would probably play the role oh
absolutely i mean this is the this is
the the substrate i mean the whole
reason i'm doing this in csew is because
i'm interested in in technology design
uh otherwise i would take my toys and go
do it in sociology but i i don't because
i'm interested in technology design and
you know part of the difficulty that
folks have been having is that
for more and more things that we're
looking at especially in csew we're very
interested in particular practices
communities cultures
that we're seeing that these
aggregations of different types of tools
software and hardware are necessary for
getting work done so it's not just i use
this one application but i use like a
series of applications and a couple
scripts and a few different pieces of
hardware right and so we were losing
that traction by trying to try to focus
it around one technology right and so
what i'm hoping is that when we get this
model to a further uh further developed
and more mature state then we can start
mapping actually aggregations and
clusters of different types of
technologies that we see in these
different types of things and it's
probably going to be domain specific
right
but this is just one layer you know the
maybe you know
charlotte gets promoted to full
professor or farther stage we start to
actually have that layer of the
technologies mapped and in the paper i
talk about that saying the johansen's
model is we have some set of
technologies and then we figure out what
types of collaborations go on it and i'm
trying to do the opposite here of saying
here all these types of collaborations
and then how how can we map the
different clusters of technologies onto
those different types of collaborations
do you think a giant
direction because
you know when i teach it
you know only in a very surface level
i leave a lot of blank
you know and say
you know what how would people interact
this way what are some examples
so they're actually kind of going in the
other direction
i'm not describing because i couldn't
hear the first part of what you're
saying i would say when i teach it i
start with the
the great blanket right because okay
what kind of
yeah and i think taking that approach
leaves more space for that dialogue of
it's not just one kind of tool that we
might be using different kinds of tools
but the fundamental you know issue
well one of the fundamental issues with
the matrix is that it still posits
location and synchronicity as
this is what we think about when we
think about collaboration
right the only important things yeah
well it's also good to have one that
break the grid
i'm all about breaking grids yeah
but yeah that's a good example